ich möchte euch heute drei verschiedene
Spots zeigen bei dem man einen super
gutes Date haben kann ist für jeden was
dabei ich werde natürlich nicht alleine
ein Date haben sondern mit meiner
wunderschönen Freundin Lara wir stehen
schon vor dem ersten Sport können uns
was leckeres zu essen zu trinken und
suchen uns ein schönes Plätzchen los
geht's
[Musik]
schön dieser Dates Spot steht und fällt
natürlich mit gutem Wetter aber so eine
schöne Begleitung und schönes Wetter hat
ne was soll da noch passiert wir suchen
uns ein schönes Plätzchen da vorne am
Wasser am besten du bist ein bisschen
überfallen
aber hast du Lust auf den Tag drei Dates
an einem Tag Hammer
ich habe eine wichtige Sache ist dass
man für ein schönes Date nicht unbedingt
in ultra teures Restaurant fahren muss
deshalb haben wir das heute so ein
bisschen steigernd aufgebaut also wir
liegen wahrscheinlich so bei 5 6 7 € für
unser Frühstück und wir steigern uns im
Laufe des Tages das heißt man kann
schöne Momente haben mit schönem Essen
und seiner Begleitung auch wenn man
nicht viel Geld ausgeht was hast du denn
bekommen Baguette mit Käse und Tomate
und ein Latte mit Hafer Milch ich habe
hier so eine Pizza mir geholt einfach
Tomate Mozzarella unten habe ich noch so
zwei süße passt die Terrier nennt man
das glaube ich so diese mandelgebäcke
leider wir waren zu spät
erinnert euch vielleicht wir waren schon
mal hier um 5 € Video und wir genießen
den Ausblick vielleicht zeigen
Betroffenen Vibes einfach es ist sehr
schön hier sehr sehr schön ich habe das
Gefühl so der Winter ist so langsam aber
sicher vorbei Kaffee ist sowieso super
das muss noch einmal sagen italienischer
Kaffee sobald ein Italiener die
Kaffeemaschine bedient ne ist das
einfach was ganz anderes der schmeckt
einfach besser egal ob man Bescheid die
coffee mit Feinwaage oder sonst was
machst du es ist irgendwie was anderes
sehr lecker wenn wir jetzt nicht schon
über 3 Jahre zusammen werden sondern das
wäre unser erstes Date sag ganz ehrlich
was würdest du denken ja also wenn das
Wetter so ist dann wenn es schön
machen ich bin ja Strategie kann man
machen ich meine man sitzt hier die
Sonne scheint und hört ein bisschen die
Vögel zwitschern kann sich gut
unterhalten hat einen schönen Rahmen
einfach für ein Date und hat dafür
deutlich unter 10 € ausgegeben deshalb
kann man auf jeden Fall machen lassen
ein guter Tipp solche Orte gibt es in
jeder Stadt dafür muss man nicht in Köln
sein ich meine es kann auch einfach ein
Bäcker sein holt euch bei einem bei
einem coolen Wecker was Papa Max erklärt
euch das nicht ich weiß sehr romantische
Stimmung bestimmen
kann
wirklich aber ich glaube vielleicht sind
die da so krass auf Abstand dass das
nicht so wahrgenommen wird
ist das nicht herrlich doch wirklich ich
glaube wir haben uns einen guten Tag
diese Woche ausgesucht und dieses Video
zu machen weil so schön war es lange
nicht mehr ich habe gerade überlegt was
war unser erstes Date nochmal ich weiß
es natürlich habe es nur für die Kamera
gesagt wir waren Sushi essen
Köln
ich habe nämlich erst Laras Instagram
gestalkt gesehen dass sie gerne Sushi
ist und dann habe ich Essen war nicht
ganz schrecklich augenscheinlich ne
Pizza verdrückt Pulli ist dreckig jetzt
noch ein bisschen Mandel Weg ist doch
ein schöner Tag
am Anfang dass wir so drei verschiedene
Dates machen ne aber alles zusammen wäre
ja das ultimative day stell mal vor
manche Leute würden auch alles vor alles
machen dazwischen noch so Aktivitäten
das wäre cool oder so muss ich ein Date
sein könnte machen oder mit einer
Freundin natürlich auch nicht sehr
schöner Tagesanfang jetzt gehen wir noch
eine Runde spazieren irgendwann bald
gibt's auch schon wieder Mittagessen
mittags Date möchte ich sagen
unser nächster Spot ist tanika und hier
werden wir jetzt einen romantisches
mittagsdate genießen
du kannst den Kanal übernehmen hier war
ich schon ganz oft ohne Kamera ich zeige
euch das Restaurant zum ersten Mal
schauen wir mal rein
[Musik]
so wenn jemand einen Blick auf die Karte
Werft dann seht ihr erstmal faire Preise
Risotto für 15 € aber hier ist immer
eine Vorspeise mit dabei also es gibt
immer entweder eine Suppe einen kleinen
Salat Bruschetta das in dem Ambiente
deshalb absoluter Trick wenn man nicht
ganz so viel Geld ausgeben kann oder
will könnte
der Klassiker hier Fischgericht mit
Wirsing Bratkartoffeln mit 16 50 also
wirklich top das hier ist das
Hauptgericht und es kann sich wirklich
sehen lassen einmal die trüffelnudeln
mit frisch gehobelt und Trüffel und Date
Klassiker sagen und hier drüben ein
Rumpsteak Wirsing Bratkartoffeln das
hier für 16,50 das für 21 50 das der
trüffelbohne ist mit nach Vorspeise die
auch gleich sehen werdet und ich finde
die Kreation cool das was
abwechslungsreich ist das Problem
das ist schon was für ein besonderen
Anlass für etwas wie ein Date sehr sehr
sehr lecker
entweder gemischter Salat Fischsuppe
also auch hier Wanderprogramm wirklich
die Trüffeln sind wirklich sehr krank
das glaube ich wirklich ein wertvoller
Tipp für alle die gerne essen gehen
schaut euch die Mittagsmenüs an auch für
ein Date dann geht man danach noch
spazieren holt sich irgendwie noch ein
Drink irgendwie am Kiosk oder so ne muss
nicht immer teuer sein wenn man jetzt
ein Date hat mit einer Person die die
man selbst am Essen interessiert ist
dann finde ich es so ein Restaurant was
ein bisschen außergewöhnlich kocht auch
immer eine gute Wahl Carbonara Bolognese
Boom Klassiker kann man nicht viel
drüber reden so diese Kombination ist
jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen sehr weit
gegriffen aber ich finde das ist auch
irgendwie so ein bisschen inspirierend
ist der so kreativ ist halt einfach und
das Ambiente ist auch so perfekt um
keine Ahnung quatschen genau
so die andere Person denkt dann anders
über die Person die das ausgewählt hat
oder man denkt so
im Meer über ihn erfahren die Fischsuppe
probieren wow wow die Schallert richtig
und das beste ist in die Begleitung
hatte man auch die Trüffeln auch noch
essen
hat ein schönes Date bei einem
Mittagsmenü und heute Abend lassen wir
es krachen
[Musik]
schön ein Grundrahmen wieder hier zu
sein wir sind vor Puls dem Restaurant
Puls dass ihr euch gezeigt habe bei ein
Tag Neueröffnung part 2 da kam es
wirklich viel zu kurz wie toll dieses
Restaurant wirklich ist und ich glaube
auch wenn ich ein Date mit Lara hätte
wäre das auch meine erste Anlaufstelle
wir waren auch schon mal privat auf dem
Date hier weil es ist einfach wirklich
ein tolles Restaurant ein tolles
Ambiente es gibt gute Drinks und ihr
werdet lieben
[Musik]
Max meint ja eben wir waren schon mal
hier und an das was mich auf jeden Fall
erinnern kann ist dieses Krankenhaus
gebracht mit dieser Creme ich weiß nicht
genau was es ist einfach so ein
römischer Frischkäse der Knoblauch hat
ne aber das gute ist das kriegt jeder
das gibt's immer das heißt alle haben
Knoblauch vorne vielen Dank danke schön
wow danke schön vielen Dank danke schön
das ist einer der Faktoren der das Puls
wirklich zu einem perfekten Dates Wort
macht diese Drinks sind wirklich
erstklassig also egal ob du nicht eine
reine Basis ein reines Bar Konzert die
sind so gut wirklich ich liebe die
Drinks mascal Paloma klingt sehr sehr
gerne letzter Zeit und natürlich für ein
gutes Datings auch nicht verkehrt das
Essen ist zum Teilen ausgelegt das ist
so super kommunikativ
das ist sehr sehr edel also ich glaube
hier kann man richtig Eindruck finden
und man kann vor allem gut essen worauf
ich nicht mindestens genauso freue wie
ein Hund das ist halt einfach so
Qualität und Expertise die natürlich
teurer ist als sie können besondere
Menschen können besonders Date kann man
das auf jeden Fall mal machen das sieht
aus wie ein Chiliöl gebraten oder so
[Musik]
und das ist zwar nur das Brot das
bestellt man nicht mal
unsere Starter sind da und ihr seht
direkt was für eine Sprache gesprochen
wird das Ding ist wirklich so in Sachen
Präsentation und Kochkunst das kommt ja
auch unter anderem aus der Füller von
schweren Kopf es ist zwanglos es ist
irgendwie entspannt und man hat trotzdem
das Essen das so gut ist nämlich im
letzten Jahr Leute gefragt haben hey Wo
muss ich mal essen gehen können ich habe
immer kurz gesagt und insbesondere im
Anwendungsfall Dates ist das glaube ich
ungeschlagen wie gesagt sind wir auch
preislich an der Spitze angekommen nur
damit ihr es ungefähr wisst dieser
Minibagger 12 Euro das Tata 16 Makrele 8
also das ist wirklich was für die
besonderen Anlässe wenn ihr euch ganz
sicher seid mit dem Date dann kommt
hierher ich würde sagen wir testen uns
einfach mal durch Romana Salatblatt
Nocke von rindertata ein zwei Cremes
oben drauf
das ist so mit Pinzette angerichtet hat
alles ne also ganz krass Sterne Niveau
also du wirst so geschmacklich einmal
durch die ganze Welt gescheuchtung mit
safrankartoffeln
geflammter Chicorée die Bitterkeit
entzogen wurde
schmeckt auch genauso gut wie es
aussieht
danke schön ich bin wirklich nach dem
Tag heute auch mehr als gut gesättigt
aber darauf freue ich mich jetzt noch
sehr hanging tender mit trüffelgi eine
kichererbsengericht komplett vegan mit
Kichererbsen Patty dann noch Soße diesen
kleinen Crackern wild brokkolibur Pommes
die wir einmal in unsere vegane Aioli
denken können und dann
finde das schmeckt irgendwie
orientalisch dieses kichererbsengerichte
irgendwie geröstete Paprika dazu sehr
lecker
[Musik]
was kann ich euch sagen wirklich ein
sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr leckerer Tag
geht zu Ende ich glaube wir konnten euch
einige schöne Date Ideen zeigen weil das
Valentinstag kocht was schönes geht was
schönes Essen wenn ihr keine Person habt
dann gönnt euch selbst was schönes
hoffentlich war für euch was dabei
vielen Dank fürs zusehen das gerne liken
ein Abo da bis zum nächsten Mal ciao